Savannah chrisley has a new man it's
gonna be an athlete then I want a
baseball player so if we don't like and
we ain't got to deal with it except in
the offseason my gosh the chrisley knows
best star took to Instagram on Thursday
to confirm that she's dating NBA player
Luke Cunard
the 19 year old was by her man's side on
Thursday as he was drafted to the
Detroit Pistons posting this shot from
the official ceremony and writing yep
y'all he's my guy could not be more
proud of him thank you for choosing me
and if that didn't make it official
enough she added the hashtag my
boyfriend is hot ét caught up with the
teen and her dad Todd in February I want
you to be with someone that you could
have a future with somebody that I'm
gonna lie and she dished on what she's
looking for in a boyfriend I just want
to find someone who understands my life
who understands the things that I deal
with the things that I go through and it
doesn't matter if they have a name or if
they don't you know if they understand
it then great but not going to use me
that's one thing